alors est ce que c'est en ces temps tu
pourras être néfaste bien sûr et c'est
une question un peu provocatrice a vu à
quel point j admire david et je pense
que c'est le meilleur youtuber
francophone chaque vidéo ils
m'impressionnent et je n'arrive pas à
comprendre comment la va être aussi
clair aussi précis et aussi complet et
aussi compréhensive veut à la fois donc
s'agit absolument pas de dire que ce que
je fais est mieux que ce que fait david
a sinon passera le contraire en fait
saviez vous essayez de critiquer
finalement le meilleur d'entre nous ce
qui rappelle parfois le boss de la
vulgarisation en tout cas thibault et
moi et je pense à raison forcément s'il
utilise cette expression c'est que je
pense qu'elle est valide dans cette
vidéo on va quand même essayer de
critiquer david est de voir que
peut-être celle que c'est pas si clair
que david et brême avant l'apport
toujours bénéfique dans ces vidéos et si
c'est le cas de david j'ai envie de dire
que c'est certainement le cas de duras
d'entre nous autres pauvres
vulgarisateur qui arrivant à peine à la
cheville de ce boss de la vulgarisation
et en fait si je suis venu à faire cette
vidéo d'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment en
fait là la culmination d'une suite de
réflexions qui ont commencé avec la ch
jacques bachmann qui ont pas mal été axé
récemment suite à une vidéo de
guinguette sur le net et intellectuels
et les nombreuses réflexions qui ont
émergé de la notamment sur la chaîne fox
en vo techno prog nous serons un peu
très vivement la série est également le
cuisent bayésiens de lui faut qu'on
entre en paradant un autre dans une
autre vidéo de la chabiba tant mieux
tous ces outils m'ont fait me demander
davantage reste je suis vraiment honnête
avec moi même
j'essaie vraiment de mesurer l'impact de
mes vidéos ou des vidéos de david
qu'est-ce que je devrais être amené à
conclure et malheureusement c'est pas
assez le constat est finalement assez
mitigé et j'en viens même à la
conclusion que il me semble probable
désormais que les vidéos de david sont
en fait néfaste pour moi une une
proportion mais non négligeable de ses
joueurs voire peut être pour la majorité
d'entre eux ce qui ferait un sas est
désastreux ok on va essayer de disséquer
pourquoi est-ce que ça me semble
probable
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire mûrir
votre ordinateur pour rendre vidéo - et
face
donc pas réussi tout cela en fait l'une
des premières vidéos qui va vraiment
alerter sur le danger de vidéos
éducatives potentiellement néfastes
alors que la vidéo éducative est
totalement juste a dit que des choses
qui sont consensus scientifique
c'est une vidéo de derek miller de un
film veritas yen où il parle de cette
thèse
luis attaque le directement un autre
youtuber éducatif à savoir c'est ma
canne de la khan academy qui est sans
doute la chine qui a le plus de pros de
contenus éducatifs et le constat de
derek miller qui en fait sa thèse parce
qu'il a fait une thèse sur l'efficacité
des vidéos scientifique est vraiment
catastrophique vraiment catastrophique
evreux faucons du monde allez voir cette
vidéo cercle des élèves qu'ils savaient
qu'ils allaient qu'ils allaient être
notés ya pas l excuse de on est juste
sur youtube comme ça dans ses rangs des
élèves qui sont envahis lyon et du grès
qu'il passe une expérience scientifique
qui sont les sujets d'une expérience
enrichie qu on leur donne des
questionnaires voilà notamment
ils ont des notes qui sont souverains
pas terrible déjà ensuite on leur montre
une vidéo éducative parfaitement justes
qui explique exactement le phénomène qui
qui doit être compris pourquoi résoudre
l'examen ni plus ni moins bah c'est pas
comme si leur formation était noyée dans
les principes très clairs tout est très
juste et très bien expliqué il se trouve
que les élèves
après avoir vu cette vidéo ne progresse
un tout petit peu mais sans dépasser
très très minimal et surtout c'est ça le
plus préoccupant ils augmentent leur
confiance en leurs réponses ils passent
en excès de confiance
y compris sur des croyances qui était
erroné
dire que le visionnage de vidéos qui
contredisent l'intuition des viewers les
étudiants a déjà usé lueurs sur youtube
des étudiants augmente
leurs créances en leur croyance erronée
je pense que ces résultats devraient
vraiment interpellé c'est vraiment
vraiment catastrophique
et ça ça montre que à mon sens beaucoup
des vidéos scientifiques sont sans doute
en fait néfaste parce que soit là d'un
des gros prennent des débats c'est
patent est ce que les gens on encaisse
un record selon sur le sujet on a tort
mais le plus gros problème c'est qu'en
plus on est en excès de confiance sur le
sujet et là par contre dès qu'on en est
que cette confiance ça devient beaucoup
beaucoup plus difficile d'avoir un débat
constructif mais également juste
d'apprendre
parce qu on se renferme sur nos propres
convictions à l'avant le chance que
l'excès de confiance et un des pires
fléaux ans et c'est ce qui empêche
l'apprentissage et du coup fait que des
vidéos éducatives augmenterez que cette
confiance c'est à dire que nous devons
empêcher la frontière et futur os qui
paraît catastrophique
lorsqu'un est intéressant c'est que
derek miller du coup propose dans sa
thèse de façon de corriger le problème
de faire des vidéos qui sont vraiment
qu'ils ont vraiment un effet important
non seulement sur ce que les gens
apprennent mais également sur leurs
excès de confiance et donc l'idée si
vous avez vu les premières vidéos de
derek miller c'est vraiment de souligner
l'intuition naïve compte par la loi est
de montrer en quoi les problématiques de
montrer notamment des gens qui se
rendent compte à quel point ces
problématiques et ça ça a l'air c'est
beaucoup plus efficace en récession les
résultats ensuite aux tests beaucoup
beaucoup plus importe beaucoup mieux
quand il ya un programme vraiment
important en plus de salles et les
élèves ne vont pas avoir un excès de
confiance en décrivant ses revenus et
donc ces vidéos sont un produit qui
l'avait obligé à semble largement
meilleur là où il ya un truc un peu
dérangeant toutefois c'est que le
ressenti des élèves n'est pas du tout ne
va pas du tout dans ce sens lire dans
les vidéos super bien expliquer où tout
est correct on veut dire mes vidéos que
fait david balaie les gens trouvent ça
super clair il discourt sa part fait
parfaitement expliqué ils sont très
contents du contenu s'il ya des
évaluations de professeurs avaient avant
un excellent alors que dans le deuxième
cas le cas où les élèves apprennent
vraiment quelque chose
ce qu'ils disent de des vidéos c'est
plus que j'ai un côté frustrant a
accompli confusion accès computing il y
avait quelque chose qui trouvait
troublant et il n'arrivait pas à y du
cui qui n'est pas du tout d'appréciation
de la vidéo mais par contre c'est un pas
que pédagogique des vidéos et beaucoup
beaucoup plus importants voix et qui est
beaucoup moins néfaste en particulier et
du coup on pourra se dire bah du coup vu
que derek miller est celui qui a
découvert
qu'est ce qui fait qu'une vidéo et
pédagogique et que c'est l'un des plus
grands pédagogues sur internet
aujourd'hui
bah il va appliquer ses méthodes sauf
que sur regarder bright food et dernière
vidéo de derek nuit heure
quasiment tout il est arrêté faire ça
c'est à dire que ce qu'il a montré dans
sa thèse à savoir le fait que certains
que nous sommes encore plus efficace a
été complètement ignorés
en fait tous les vulgarisateurs du web
mais y compris celui qui a fait cette
découverte qui en a fait et qui a fait
plusieurs vidéos sur le sujet derek
miller a arrêté de faire des vidéos qui
sont pédagogiquement efficace pourquoi
c'est à dire mais voilà quand tu vois on
est sensible au nom de vue que font nos
vidéos on également très sensible aux
commentaires
avec un commentaire qui a vidéo est
super clair va ça va nous renforcer
positivement dans ce qu'on fait et on
vivait un commentaire qui lire la vidéo
a été confuse j'ai pas très bien compris
bah ça ça va nous tuer à ne plus faire
ce genre de vidéos et de fil en aiguille
on se retrouve avec des vidéos qui
seront très claires qui explique
exactement ce qu'il faut expliquer de
façon complètement juste mais qui du
coup sont potentiellement
pédagogiquement n'efface et ça comme
très préoccupant d'autant qu'au cours de
ces derniers mois il ya un autre graf
qui m'a pas mal interpellé
c'est ce que je la galette rappelle la
courbe du désespoir une vidéo
d'alexandre technique rock sur le sujet
qui montre que plus on en sait sur le
sujet parlant de changement climatique
plus on se renforce dans les idées
défendues par notre parti politique
donc je pense que sur des sujets voilà
on a des partis pris et où le biais de
confirmation le risque d'auto ball site
est énorme
en fait des contenus solide
scientifiquement parfaitement clair
super bien expliqué pour être en fait
extrêmement néfaste sur des primes en
tout ce que j'attends
en parlant de déprime je vais finir avec
une petite note qui est le risque d'auto
bullshit la part des vulgarisateurs
parce que tous ces résultats je le
connais depuis en tout cas celui de
derek noir je suis voilà je suis vidé
enfin j'ai vu la vidéo quand elle est
sortie en 2012 1013 passe comme ça voire
bah ça fait bientôt presque une décennie
que je connaissais résultat et je pense
que j'ai eu tendance à les négliger
quand c'est j'ai tendance à les mettre
de côté
moi aussi à les oublier régulièrement et
du coup à ne pas en prendre compte la
moto bouchité à penser que mes vidéos
sont clairement bénéfique alors que as
puisque c'est un monstre c'est que on
manque de retour en fait sur nos vidéos
et les eaux pures tour qu'on a sauvé
retour immédiat c'est des effets à court
terme
du coup on risque de passer complètement
à côté des effets à long terme qui
peuvent être en fait très néfastes
notamment via le problème de l'excès de
confiance
du coup je pense qu'une des priorités à
ça ferait enfin des trucs à renforcer
beaucoup plus c'est communiqué de telle
manière que les excès de confiance en
des croyances erronées soient combattues
et soit soit diminue heureusement ce
n'est pas facile et surtout c'est pas ça
qui va nous donner beaucoup de vue pas
ça qui va nous donner beaucoup d'abonnés
avoir savoir faire fuir les gens
détriment
déprimant